Student W.Q. Feng asked when do you use a recursive definition versus a 'while' loop?
So this is a good question and in terms of being able to solve a problem,
anything you can do with recursion you can also do with a 'while' loop.
Anything you can do with a 'while' loop you could also do with recursion.
So any problem you can solve either way.
Usually solving it with a 'while' loop would be more efficient
because you don’t have the overhead of all the extra procedure calls.
Often solving it with recursion is a simpler and more elegant solution.
So depending on what’s more important, oftentimes the tradeoff
is much better where the simpler elegant solution
that performance difference you probably couldn’t even measure
unless you were timing really carefully for really large inputs,
you wouldn’t notice the difference.
So it’s more important to get the solution correct and have it
in code that’s easier for you to write and easier for other people to understand,
in many problems the recursive solution
really lends itself to that. It’s much shorter than the iterative solution would be
and it’s easier to understand and follow.
In places where performance matters and we saw this with the Fibonacci example
that if you end up blowing up the number of calls in a way
that makes it too slow to do recursively,
you might prefer a more complicated solution that involves a 'while' loop and avoids the recursive calls.